so the problem
is that all of their data
right first of all it's based on a
somewhat biased sample it's based on all
people
who were in the 2011 census in the uk
in 2011 and who were registered with a
gp in
2019 right so it's a subset of the
population they're making all these
estimates about the proportion of
unvaccinated uh in the population based
on that it's quite you know it's quite a
it's not you know it's not an exhaust
it's nothing like an exhaustive subset
for a start
right so that's their data right but
they're getting information so obviously
they've got data on deaths and they're
supposed to have accurate data on
vaccination status of
everybody body there but of course what
we know is happening
um i'm sure they're saying that you
you know you'll be aware of as well is
that
the whether or not someone is classified
as vaccinated or not
right or one those two those three does
whatever
is is susceptible to let's say
significant manipulation some of it
deliberate some but not so in the case
of we know that for any of effectiveness
effectiveness studies they'll classify
they'll say well you can't consider the
vaccine to be effective until you've had
it for two weeks so anybody who gets
covered in that time we we don't count
them as as a coded case you've got this
unbelievable built-in bias where you're
guaranteed even with a even with a known
um placebo you're given you'd get a
statistical artifact which shows very
high
efficacy
and then waiting i understood that now
it's a pure statistical artificial pure
statistical artifact you get that um
similarly if you get delayed reporting
you get the same thing but the same
thing happens with deaths and this is
really bad so they will say
they'll claim no we we
if someone
has had the vaccine and dies 24 hours
later no we classify that as a
vaccinated death no we know that doesn't
happen
we know that most of the people who die
shortly after the first dose are
classified as unvaccinated we know that
most of people who die shortly after
the second dose classified as one though
so you get this again this
misclassification and that
misclassification is skewing all of
their data right to the extent that we
actually and also we know
right so that that skews any results
they claim about safety and effect
efficacy because they claim well no the
data's showing that that is both you
know safe safe and effective but we also
showed
um
that hey it couldn't be true because
actually what happens is that when you
look at their own data you do a plot of
the what happens with oracle's
non-covered deaths
shortly after the roll out of
vaccination you get this bizarre thing
whereby the unvaccinated get a peak in
non-covered deaths when the vaccination
program was rolled out so somehow
when you're vaccinating a whole load of
people all those who aren't getting
vaccinated are suddenly dying of
diseases that proves that there's a
well
non-covered
misclassification and you know they came
with this ridiculous idea we challenged
them we spoke at them about it said oh
well that's the that's the healthy
vaccine effect we proved that couldn't
be the case by looking at looking at
historical data so we but they're still
maintaining it but now the big thing is
they've got this all the data is based
on a bizarre
literally a bizarre underestimate
of the proportion of people who actually
aren't vaccinated in the uk so they
claim
that only
four million which is eight percent of
uk adults are unvaccinated
now if you if you underestimate that
proportion and that's the denominator in
all of your effectiveness and safety
things and obviously you're going to
massively exaggerate the effectiveness
and safety of the vaccine which is what
they're doing
well we've we've challenged them on this
there are other other government
agencies
so the same uk government another agency
called the united kingdom health
security agency is saying that over 20
percent
of adults are unvaccinated there's a big
difference from 20 and 8 percent if
you're using that as a denominator
everything switches with that with the
uk hsa denominator you get in every
single age group you get an increase a
significant increase in all cause
mortality so let me understand
vaccinated if there are more
unvaccinated then
are being allowed for certain
calculations
then the fact that they are not
experiencing an increase in negative
health effects that are downstream
effectively the vaccines are borrowing
some of the health of unvaccinated
people exactly to increase the
appearance that they are safe that's
exactly it simple as that oh yeah yeah
um
i've been i've been like on loads i've
done loads of podcasts last two weeks
because there was a
two documentary called unvaccinated
which fell enough was hosted by hannah
fryer was my co-presenter when i
you know did my bbc documentary but
she's gone on since then you know to be
very famous she's like now like the lead
she's like the face of science in the uk
so she did this program called
unvaccinated which is the most biased
unbelievably biased program they got
seven
unvaccinated people and tried to
basically convince them over a week to
get
vaccinated they wanted to supposedly
they tried it was supposed to be
objective you know they were supposed to
say to say give them you know arguments
you know both ways and find out why they
weren't vaccinated but it was the most
fire singer they brought in the experts
and felt they failed to declare
these people like fires are that strong
association of fires these are the
experts so all that anyway but the
interest you know it was really
interesting i picked up on this point
about it is at the start of the program
they so the reason i picked my ears up
that's first started blogging about it
was because they were making this claim
about only only about only eight percent
unvaccinated and they were trying to
claim this is some tiny fringe crazy
minority and i knew that figure was
wrong i knew that was based on this
wrong ons data so i started to raise a
concern straight away
but the program and they actually
obviously to be fair they changed the
headline on one of their articles which
was
you know advertising the program they
took that they took that
eight that four million or eight percent
off the headline but it was still a key
feature of programs the program started
with hannah fryer saying
despite you know this great vaccine
vaccination program you know there's
still four million uk adults who are
unvaccinated right 80
making out making out that was far too
big a number right
right but you know what she said this is
incredible and i then checked out and i
looked at the source for this she said
that in preparation for the program the
bbc had done their own
large survey representative
uh survey
of over 2 500 uk adults
and they found
that
600 well it was actually which was 24
and actually we looked at the source
data from this study it really was a
very good
survey it was actually 26 unvaccinated
and that's a big sample that's a big
sample in fact you know
using sort of standard statistical
organs that means the probability that
the true number is less than 20 percent
unvaccinated is effectively zero so
there really are you know there really
are over 20
unvaccinated contrary to what you know
is the basis for all of these safety and
efficacy claims
you know the whole covid
evidentiary picture
is just it's like a hall of mirrors
right you are looking at something and
you have no idea whether it's an actual
something
or a created something or a
misinterpretation of something but
the
let's put it this way
i hope it is a complex problem
it's not this complex right we have
hundreds of years frankly of work
figuring out how you analyze things
we've gotten good at analyzing for
simple patterns like
you know if you had this treatment are
you more or less likely to die over x
period of time that's not a difficult
problem
so the fact that
we can't get anything right
we can't say things definitively because
the entire thing has been reduced to
some kind of bizarre team sport
it's unreal right it's not this hard get
some smart people put them in a room
immunize them from bad consequences and
have them talk about how you would
figure out where we are and what to do
about it
if it's not going to happen is it it's
too late it's too it's too polarized
yeah no no they've um
they've committed themselves
because if we were to do that it would
reveal the level of
at the very least
indifference to human death and
suffering
[Music]
you